which one of these Apple gadgets is the
odd one out did you get it the answer is
this 2013 Mac Pro not because it looks
like a trash can but because it's the
only one that was assembled in the USA
the others were assembled in China why
is that important
Apple makes their product in China I
told Tim Cook who's a friend of mine who
I like a lot make you product in the
United States build those big beautiful
plants that go on for miles it seems
president Trump who is currently in the
midst of a trade war with China wants
these Apple products to be more like
this one actually he wants them to be
fully made in the USA but Apple one of
the company's most exposed to the trade
war has one of the largest most deeply
integrated global supply chains so could
Apple ever move production back to the
US
we've taxed China on 300 billion dollars
worth of goods and products being sold
into our country
Trump's threat of imposing fresh tariffs
could drive the cost of Apple's iPhone
excess up by about $40 fortunately for
Apple that tariff has been postponed
until December 15th and an earlier round
of tariffs on circuit boards and
computer chips has had minimal impact on
the company as China and the u.s. keep
fighting over trade Apple is already
moving some of its production to avoid
tariffs and trade duties like to India
for example where many of Apple's major
suppliers are relocating that's no mean
feat the company moved production out of
the u.s. years ago building a global
supply network it lists suppliers in
over 25 countries with some parts made
in China since the early 2000s the way
that I view this is the vast majority of
our products are kind of made everywhere
largely I think that will carry the day
in the future as well others before
Trump have tried to get Apple to bring
jobs back to America president Obama
reportedly asked Steve Jobs what it
would take to make iPhones in the u.s.
twitch jobs
those jobs aren't coming back will there
be an Apple product ever made again in
the United States I want there to be so
will it ever say on the back of an Apple
product designed in California assembled
in the United States in May the company
has tried before
remember that Mac Pro it is designed by
brilliant engineers in California and
assembled here in the USA a series of
deaths at its main suppliers factory
raised questions over working conditions
in Asia so the company invested 100
million dollars to assemble the Mac Pro
in Austin Texas
the reason the Mac Pro was moved back to
the US that's because it's a pretty
low-risk product right it's not making a
ton of these so it could it could move
it here test and see if it could do us
manufacturing and if so then it could
explore the opportunity for other
products but the plant in Austin had
issues when it came to locally sourcing
enough components for the production of
the Mac Pro leading to delays so what
did the company do they imported some of
the parts from China where manufacturers
had capacity to keep up with demands
how many tool and die makers do you know
in the US now we could have I could call
a meeting around the United States and
say what every tool and die maker come
to this room tonight we wouldn't feel
the road in China you would need several
cities recently production in the Austin
plant has fizzled out and production of
the new Mac Pro this is the new Mac Pro
has been relocated back to China
according to people familiar with the
plans with the new Mac Pro it's not hard
at all to shift production back to China
this is Apple's playbook right they've
perfected the art of making things in
China so transitioning the Mac Pro or
any other product to China makes a lot
of sense for them so what are Apple's
choices if they want to navigate the
tariffs they have three options given
how expensive and complex moving out is
Apple may just decide to stay in China
and at some point potentially pay
tariffs which would likely make Apple
products more expense
or Apple can move manufacturing just not
to the US India and Vietnam are only two
of the countries that are hoping to
learn Apple and its suppliers finally if
the company could strike an agreement
with Trump Tim was talking to me about
tariffs and you know one of the things
and he made a good case is that Samsung
is their number-one competitor and
Samsung is not paying terrorists because
they're based in South Korea that's
tough for Apple to pay tariffs if
they're competing and I thought he made
a very compelling argument so I'm
thinking about it
in July Cook said tariff exclusions are
key for Apple to make the new Mac Pro in
America that's what's behind the
exclusions and so we're we're explaining
that and hope for positive outcome we
contacted Apple following the latest
round of tariffs but the company
declined to comment further Apple hasn't
recently moved any of its manufacturing
back to the US but it says it spent 60
billion dollars with 9,000 u.s.
suppliers and companies last year
supporting 450,000 jobs they're even
building a new campus in Austin Texas
the same city where that Mac Pro is no
longer being assembled